la red más grande de oleoductos de eeuu
mantiene cerrados sus grifos la razón un
intento de extorsión desde la comodidad
de una pantalla la casa blanca agentes
del fbi y una firma privada experta en
ciberataques trabajan para restablecer
la operación si bien nuestras líneas
principales permanecen fuera de línea
algunas más pequeñas ahora están
operativas pondremos a funcionar nuestro
sistema completamente sólo cuando
consideremos que es seguro hacerlo y en
total cumplimiento de todas las
regulaciones federales colonial pipeline
fue víctima del viernes de un ataque de
ransomware esta es una creciente
modalidad extorsiva dirigida a grandes
organizaciones en la que piratas
informáticos secuestran datos a cambio
de pagos en monedas digitales la
parálisis de kolonial pipeline comienza
a preocupar a los consumidores su
extensa red de casi 9000 kilómetros
atraviesa al menos 13 estados del sur y
la costa este desde texas hasta nueva
jersey transporta más de 25 millones de
barriles por día de gasolina y otros
combustibles que representan casi la
mitad del suministro de la zona entre
sus clientes están algunos de los
principales aeropuertos
incluido el dejar su piel de jackson de
atlanta el más transitado del mundo por
número de pasajeros
teniendo en cuenta que la empresa
entrega a estas terminales aéreas cada
cinco días se puede ver un impacto
generalizado mucho mayor en el día 4 o 5
a lo largo del atlántico medio y el
sureste del país y eso ciertamente sería
preocupante para el consumidor las
aerolíneas o incluso los usuarios de
combustible diésel para la industria de
camiones y ferrocarriles
la interrupción no deja por ahora
grandes problemas de suministro pero sí
generó preocupación entre varios
legisladores quienes hicieron un llamado
para fortalecer la seguridad de la
industria energética